hey guys I'm back with another video on
the perfect intermittent fasting ratio
for maximum fat burning I do get this
question a lot at what ratio should I do
the eating vs. fasting cycle to just
produce the most weight loss okay well
there's some research that was done that
shows that you're gonna mobilize the
most fat and lower the most insulin
right around 18 hours to 24 hours okay
in a cycle so let's look at this more
closely here we have 18 hours of fasting
okay let's say you eat at 12 o'clock
noon and then at 6 it gives you 6 hour
window of eating right and then you're
gonna fast for 18 hours so you're gonna
lose some weight it's gonna be very
successful so let's say you ate one meal
at 12 o'clock
okay that gives you like a 23 hour
fasting cycle so somewhere in between
here would be the optimum so a lot of
you out there are doing in a min fasting
and you're just doing one meal a day in
fact nearly a hundred percent of all the
Skype interviews that I have done one
meal a day so they're doing very very
well but if you're new at this what you
could do is go to three meals then push
the breakfast further and further and
further until eventually there's no
breakfast because you don't want to eat
in the morning when you're not hungry
and then you have two meals right so
then what you want to do is you want to
keep pushing this 12 o'clock to 1 and
this 6 to 5 to shorten this down to a 4
hour window that would be a real nice
sweet spot to hit between 4 hours and if
you want to take one step further and
start graduating to this over here you
can do it I would do this if you need to
lose a lot of weight also the more you
have insulin resistance the more damage
within your system the more that you
have diabetes the more you want to
graduate into this right here but let's
say for example you're losing weight you
hit your goal and you're comfortable and
you don't have a history of blood sugars
it stick with something like this okay
but the other benefit of doing this
longer okay maybe you might not want to
do this but maybe a four-hour window is
something called a tapa G which most of
you seen the
I've done this butter toffee G is like
yourselves being a self-cleaning oven
okay where it's cleaning up all this
crap out of the cells it's recycling all
the junk it's getting the junk out of
the trunk so in a minute of fasting can
increase the toffee G by five times okay
so it's a very powerful stimulus of
toffee G which will make yourselves very
healthy as compared to a diabetic who
has very dirty cells
there's no self-cleaning oven there's
waste products there is all sorts of
damage to the eyes to the retina to the
kidneys to the heart so etapa G is what
you want to do especially if you're
diabetic or pre-diabetic one small point
about diabetics if a diabetic were to
consume more B vitamins from nutritional
yeast they would have less damage to the
mitochondria and less waste build-up all
right just a side note so for the people
that want to take it all the way and do
one meal a day you can also take an even
further by adding high-intensity
interval training exercise in your
fasting window whether it's before or
after and you add that to one meal a day
now you're talking about taking it to
the next level because you're gonna
spike growth hormone you're gonna lose a
lot more weight doing that and also
adding a little more sleep will help you
as well make sure you don't over train
make sure you're recovering you know
some people are working out six days a
week
I recommend twice a week okay if you're
doing this correctly and you're hitting
it hard the personal trainer think twice
a week is fine unless you're 20 years
old you know but if you're thirty forty
fifty twice a week is the perfect
optimum frequency of workouts but then
on the off days do the walking that
would be hot also keep your carbs lower
than 20 grams and the vegetables in as
well but keep those carbs at less than
20 grams not counting vegetables and I
think this right here you're gonna have
some serious weight loss and you're
gonna be happy with that pattern thanks
for watching hey thank you so much for
watching keep spreading the word in
share this video